was tight on an mtv but there was no
murder in it that was the thing i
thought in the end somebody died it's
just people
throwing a ball around yeah that's kind
of like the tuna subway stuff if you're
gonna
say tuna i need tuna if you're gonna say
murderball i need some murdering
yeah don't tell me murder and give me
mackerel
[Laughter]
back off my broccolini get your life
together
it
[Music]
[Applause]
guys i'm doing on dates leave me alone
okay
a date okay you're a serial dater man
not all of us have kidnapped a [ __ ]
semi-underage woman like chin has
talked about it's my girl now yeah she
works at the library sure she does dude
chen's girl has after school care
program written all over her dog
that chick is nine bro she has a body of
a nine year old
she loves it she curvy yeah
you know with my girlfriend she's curvy
that's scoliosis dude okay
and they do a check every six months at
the at the academy
she's got curves in the front
that's a stomach
one of those is bro one of those is
pregnancy dog okay
oh crap no she'd uh she has that thingy
i e
d or something dude no ied has killed
thousands of soldiers abroad
inside of her dude no is she working for
nation of islam
no no those things are 100 percent chin
i mean but the swimmers can still get
past the goalie there and score some
goals not chin swimmers dude these
things are [ __ ] bumper to bumper on
the way in dude
you ever seen a lot of chins in traffic
yeah they probably get stopped at the
gate yeah
i got to look at the accuracy because i
never really looked at it and i just i
kind of just go
do whatever oh you're disgusting
you're the chinese derrick yeah jin let
that wasabi loose
that skim milk out there bro that
vietnamese freaking coconut milk dog you
better tighten up
chin god wants you yeah
god wants you chen i know i'm a good
person
do you go to church chin no he doesn't
dude
do you sorry chin it's okay but you know
hold on you ain't no i don't
see yeah you know you don't told you bro
nick definitely doesn't but he's been
when he was with his grandma
growing up dude if you have a grandma
that you live when you're grown up
that's just like going to church
that's fair but she'd make you go uh
every sunday
not every sometimes she just don't want
to deal with the fight uh
oh you still fight her yeah i mean just
like in the yard or inside
would you go body only or did you go hit
her knees
she's got a rock hard core so you don't
want to go body with my grammy you just
tire yourself out
but three or five rounds uh but
now today when i go back home i
volunteer i'm like you don't want to go
to church i ask her first
and she always wants to go yeah it makes
you feel nice look at dude nick hits 30
000
ig followers and he's gets a bang energy
unreal cat started an oldie fans and has
an assistant now
does she really yeah
i know it's a lot man we have a single
mama on tpw that
we part of the single mom thing that we
help out sometimes and
she got an only fans we can't even get
in touch with her anymore
that's how it goes man we can't even
help her anymore she's like
i'm good you [ __ ] yeah she's like
please leave me alone man i've used your
platform enough
yeah cat got that new money got new
bangs and [ __ ]
damn she just she has new bangs yes she
is yeah
i wonder if she puts it on her instagram
or not she did no bunny bangs
that's how it goes man that's the thing
you buy a girl a waffle bro and next
thing you know you're not invited to
lunch dog that's the old saying you
ain't lying
that's the old chinese saying isn't it
chin i'm joking i know you're korean i
know
that's a joke i see
oh dicey dog checkmate dog
bobby lee you [ __ ] hear me bobby lee
sleepy [ __ ]
all right wake up dawg i'm that [ __ ]
alarm clock son yeah come get some
you want it you little gristle animal
come get it dog
come freaking get it dude there's cat
with them new bangs dude i'll
jump off the bottom rope and [ __ ]
still take you out you bastard
bobby lee yeah you're gonna hit that red
head on the way down dude i [ __ ] oh
oh yeah i'll catch that dude with you
get a little cinnamon on your elbow i'll
catch i do with my
yeah one of my hoofs i'll catch that
chatty hollywood elite with one of my
hooks
yeah he is hollywood oh dawg time i'm
sorry i can't do the show i'm
i'm on set yeah i'm on set you're on
somebody else's set dawg
set of nuts huh yeah dude setting my
deck of nuts dog you've been dating
dude i went on a date so what dude it
wasn't it was
look it wasn't that great and i had to
freaking pay for everything yeah that's
how it goes bro
and listen to this move okay so
you are you sure this one was a woman
this time oh yeah i mean i have no idea
from
there's no like physical proof but i
believe
if i had to take a if i had a lie
detector test
yeah if i had to take a lot of ticket
tests everything inside of me would say
hey this is a woman all right
i believe you i don't know if the
audience does but i do
i don't think you believe me i think
they do i think we're all skeptical
all right we're in this together um
so you've been serial dating no i
haven't until date and i just want to
know
but oh here's the thing so they got the
leftovers from the thing she didn't want
to take them right there i'm like oh
okay who's this fancy b you know what
i'm saying dude
don't wear the leftovers though if it's
like sushi or something i'm with her
she's too good to have something to eat
tomorrow bro get the
f out of here she's got the dates lined
up like no i get another meal
sucka that's fine but who got that
breakfast date you know what i'm saying
yeah you're right if you can i think if
you if you meditate first you can
psychologically convince yourself
to have chicken parm for breakfast yeah
she's not thinking ahead
and it must be nice to not have to you
know but she anyway yeah she took
my freaking uh leftover also what what
what did you order
salmon for the dog she said
oh for the dog yeah like what kind of a
friggin dog
eat [ __ ] fish baby water cattle oh
she fancy
that's what i'm saying instagram
thoughts getting ratchet
so that's what i'm thinking of right now
brian has an only fan she don't need you
you got a little freaking scottish
terrier out there polishing just
eating your salmon dog polishing off a
freaking a little bit of [ __ ] wood
seared salmon right now dude
and nick's out here with his bang energy
jesus everyone's changing everybody's
changing
what with all your [ __ ] money
all your [ __ ] money and keep throwing
your girlfriend in our face all the
gadgets
yeah trying to get reconstructive
surgery so you can look japanese
i know that korean come up dude trying
to get shorter yeah dude
definitely not i know that korean come
up dude that's that asian come up bro
it's like oh you know what yeah
i'm here then i'll do this then i'll get
my eyes wide and then i'll do this but
i'll join a band
get my ears shaved down i'll join a
k-pop then i bail out my hair
then i'm polynesian now i live oh i'm
from hawaii that's how it is
now moana's my favorite movie yeah yeah
bruh i don't want to attend
i've seen it too many times joe coy
[Laughter]
who will be in here next week huh he'll
be in here next week oh good yeah that's
our boy
will i ask him right then if you seem
different chen i shaved my head like him
so that's like joe coy yeah i'm kind of
getting yeah you
fake robert whitaker in here doug yeah
you ain't feeling nobody i know yeah
i'm just joking man you seem great man
thank you and i appreciate i'm doing
good we missed you last week man
i know it was a tough one couldn't can't
do uh the two shows and then
be here as well yeah i don't know how i
mean brendan does it
yeah it must be impossible for you to
just hit your ride with it i don't know
what happened
must be tough jen's just standing there
like man wish i could do it today
[Laughter]
we needed your thoughts on kimchi i know
we were stopped
let's talk about kimchi no dude if you
eat with meat it's like the best
combination yeah we knew you'd go hard
in the paint on it seriously
is it so is kimchi on every table in uh
your culture korean is it like on any
time you eat dinner or anything with a
family is it always
like your salt pepper yeah birthdays
thanksgiving christmas whatever if
there's always kimchi on the table
and do different people make it taste is
it taste different there's different
ones they're sour and there's fresh type
so the sour ones you age for a long time
too is it pickled
oh yeah and is it spicy chin it's not
that spicy so it looks like it's super
spicy
it's ready red and orange but it's not
that spicy
pickled cabbage is my stepmom's nickname
that's my wrestling name
was it really yeah the old pickle i
thought it was big barn or whatever
the big barn the fridge
this dude's hiding goats in his back
door that's why they call it a big barn
bro remember when uh oh did you did you
uh spend that cash you gave me on
that little instagram thought save that
money dog put in your butt
all right
you know it's still up there now look
i'll pay for that
i got eight look i still have 800 in
there okay damn you got the salmon
all right i'm gonna need another hundo
damn girl getting salmon
a waiter
[Laughter]
yeah oh she wants dessert waiter
listen dude why would you sleep on
anything all right don't sleep
underneath
your old man if you're being loud you
need sleep dude we don't yell
but you gotta do it with helix sleep
because they have a mattress that's
built just for your thick ass
who is helix is it a middle easterner no
it's not the cat either i'm talking
about helix sleep beds helix sleep
you take a quick little quiz takes two
minutes then they match you
with the perfect mattress just for your
weird
square body theo i got you covered man
but
can they do my body type i got a body
type like that uh
you know i'm built like that um like a
thick ass miley cyrus
no i'm built more like a guy that um
like a crash chest dummy that's been uh
you know on vacation for a while yeah
but you got that
big ass yeah yeah that crash just dumped
me with a big ass oh i got the j in the
tray
yeah it crashed into me helix sleep was
awarded number one best overall mattress
all right by gq and wired magazine i got
my crib i can't get rid of my
mother-in-law
father-in-law just go to helixsleep.com
k-a-t-s
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with the perfect
mattress
save 200 off all mattress orders and you
get a free pillow
if you go to helixsleep.com k-a-t-s
that's helix sleep.com k-a-t-s for up to
two hundred dollars off
crash into me satellite in my
eyes like a diamond
in the sky oh yeah dawg look
seldomfield and tidata phil are i'll be
honest two urban kids that went to my
high school yeah chappelle's cousins
yeah yeah
no they're the drugs that get you dig
better yeah
my friend like down by the dick
bus bus bus bus
if you like sex you'll love blue chew
daddy
turbo charger dick game the chewables
from blue chew can take
you can take full stomach empty stomach
it don't matter an online physician
consult
is free so it's cheaper than those uh
viagra seahawks it only takes a few
minutes
connect with bluetooth.com all right and
we'll get you covered man
no more doctor visits no more awkward
conversations about your dick game with
some doctor you don't know blue chew is
made in the u.s of a all right you guys
will love it
and uh here's the deal man visit
bluetooth.com and get your first order
free when you use the promo code kats
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluee chew.com promo code
cats if you don't have smell blue
probably shouldn't be having sex
um who was that nick that you pulled up
on the screen uh this is the return of
flop my aunt
return to thighs what's up girl these
are
two that were sent in uh sisters metal
detector because they got jewelry on the
beach
what's up daddy that bass stop oh
on the right we've got uh aunt paula 67
years old she doesn't drink
doesn't smoke doesn't cuss but she likes
to go dancing in myrtle beach and
staying out late wherever the party's at
yeah she looks like she twerks
and to that point her favorite song and
ringtone is don'tcha by the
pussycat dolls uh that goes don't you
wish you had a man
like me don't you oh
don't you don't you don't you wish your
girlfriend was
like me
now here's my problem with this uh thick
ass ant on the right
is she wearing uh socks and sandals
because that's frowned upon
in america but they got a lot of seniors
have tender feet man you can't put
tender feet in that hot sand especially
a myrtle beach are you talking about
them tenderloin feet
bro this is where they film glory dude
in myrtle beach bro some of those scenes
i mean they have cannons under the sand
you got
mtv spring break there we go servants a
lot of like anything could pop out of
that song
holly shores dna probably all over that
beach
you could trip on a hot femur out there
dude they got everything in that sample
you know how many battles were fought on
that sand
yeah you don't know you know your
grandma freaking slips on a cannonball
you know a cannibal i'm just going to
slipped on a [ __ ] musket
bro you how many hot [ __ ] musket
chunks are out there
oh great granny get [ __ ] and are
these two different people
yeah they are two i'll tell you out of
the gate even by looking at him even if
i was blind
i could tell you these are three
different people okay both of you guys i
can't
tell you bang white boy okay you got
three different people
well no i know the old the old weathered
uh sunface dude
on the left but i thought maybe those
were two of the same women
i was having trouble deciphering them as
well but the person on the left that is
the other aunt
on amy who's 65 she smokes salem
ultralights
and lassie enjoys the occasional stout
she's lived at the beach since she was
18.
she's she's the wife of an east coast
surfing legend and mother of a national
longboard champion
yes she is nervous in the ocean she
plays the ukulele guitar banjo
and harmonica and doesn't know who the
pussycat dolls are
ooh don'tcha but sisters
oh they're sister oh that makes sense
that's why they're together and now i
can see the comp
the competitiveness between them too
yeah me too you know i'll take the one
on the right
via decision one's like i'm in a long
board one's like i'm on a short bus
you know what do you uh who do you pull
here chan you're out on the beach you
know you see these freaking
uh wave riders rolling around the one in
the red for sure
yeah and why is that brother she's got
curves in the front
yeah like and probably in the back jen
she might not
brenden ah you don't have that thick and
have a flat ass
you don't do you don't say that kind of
stuff about women women more bro y'all
down the streets with these men
i don't like men on a date with women
bro it's not like you're doing that so
much you're trying to freaking do it to
yourself
but yeah that's amy and paula who do you
go for you think nick amy or paula
i use your uber days you pick up both of
them
i think i'm uh with chin on this one the
one that doesn't smoke
her looks will last longer uh with that
red she's like uh she's like an aged
pamela
anderson baywatch okay okay i think our
bay watchers were different
yeah i think you're right man she got
that more pamela anderson body
she definitely and look she cares about
her feet like the other one dude a lot
of times you get one of those sunned up
dimes man and they all sunned out yeah
they hit them raising brand feet
oh and they got they fill their ears
with uh sunscreen
yep oh man yup and then you get a white
face
oh their sun is their face is bleached
out
uh from the sun the wrinkles yeah old
leather face
yeah you call it on the streets oh
sometimes you'll see you put the you'll
fold part of their face up and put a
little money in it you think it's a
wallet
it's a hot purse yeah like oh you got
hey pull that 30 out of your neck
let me see your lip yeah yeah yeah let
me get that bottom lip
um hold on let me pick one too i'm
picking
oh you going with the thick one you
ain't ready for that
healthy one on the left sir yeah and the
one on the left has a man and she
already brought her and she also spawned
a world champion
yeah long border yeah you don't bring uh
you don't bring a man to the beach dude
so i'm gonna go with the one on the
right on paula is that paula uh
yes that's paula 67
on the right don't hurt him who are you
going right all day
really i told you via decision third
round i think you should beat that
i like that technical [ __ ] out bro
but but amy's beautiful too it's only
because they're both so beautiful that
we had to pick one
yeah oh yeah look and look obviously but
here's the thing about amy is she's you
know kind of
she's taking the road less traveled
she's been in the sun so much he's
already got a man
you know he's a badass yeah she probably
reads a lot
mm-hmm you know she probably reads
jonathan livingston seagull
it's a book yep she tried a little moby
dick yeah she's probably read
everything and she has a son you know so
if that guy dies she has somebody to
take care of her but this other lady has
sand
as socks and sandals in the hot sand she
needs
she's obviously searching for something
out there yeah she needs somebody
word uh we're moving on to a new one uh
this she
this young lady is going to introduce
her and then we'll bring up the picture
hey brennan hey theo it's been a while
since i've seen a flight iran and i
think i got a good one for you
this is my aunt bonnie she's coming to
you all the way from wisconsin
she's living her best life on one of her
favorite birthdays and she is single
and ready to mingle the girl is your
typical pollock
from a small town who loves bacardi
lamone more than anyone i know
cheers guys she she looked like her
application got denied at joe exotic zoo
oh she's i was put uncaged but she
should get a tattoo on her because on
cage man
look she's a beautiful woman she reminds
me of grant cotter who's a comedian but
in
like about 40 years maybe or 30 years
bonnie is her name beautiful and i love
those rolled up
no betty betty them rolled up levi
baggy shorts those rolled up pant legs
let's get a picture of grant cotter if
he does without a hat on
oh really i think she looks more like
tim dillon's mom maybe
i see it yeah i see tim dillon oh i can
see a little bit of that yeah and you
can
see those ears pierced that's why i'm
saying that because grant has his ears
pierced he's handsome that's the same
that's the same person
there we go man my boy gc right there an
amazing comedian out of the south bay
right there
um but yeah she got this shirt on what
does this shirt say nick
if it ain't gonna lick itself
oh look i hopefully don't hopefully
hopefully that narrows pointing to some
stamps in her
hopefully yeah she's pocket always point
to a tootsie roll cause that's
disgusting if not
hopefully she's got mail to send because
she's sending this mail the other way
i'm telling you that but i know somebody
that would get out their chin would get
in oh man bro you guys eat some wild
stuff you do eat wild stuff
caucasian nick i feel like if you picked
her up on one of your uber nights it
could get pretty wild
you got a bang energy drink a positive
attitude it's her birthday
dude she likes bacardi lemon first thing
i ever drank when i was 14 years old
of course birthdays
bro that's a wisconsin water fountain
ingredient
i love how nick snuck in another
wisconsin reference unbelievable
wisconsin
as i had so much uh so much fanfare so
much like in a murderer
i was gonna go with ron dayne but all
right um
yeah her wisconsin accent was like it
brought me back heavy
yeah but look i think this lady
obviously is a beautiful lady she has a
positive attitude it's her birthday
she has a lit shirt it's always her
birthday dude
yeah it is she also looks like uh hulk
hogan's son
or daughter if she fell on some hard
times
she also like she makes a mean meat loaf
you know
she's that one grandma who has just that
nasty stew recipe
that loaf boy daddy
yeah are you talking about that nick
hogan
yeah yeah she definitely gives me the
coke and vibes kind of
or hulk hogan
you don't want nick hogan as your uber
driver oh
true true too much no it's fine
all right i just knew it was gonna
happen you're ready for it
um is that a pop i don't know if people
know that history do we
huh is that that's not that popular that
he killed a dude i mean you didn't
have to say it then you said it
uh so we've got uh one more aunt this is
on alison
she is an aunt she's only 30 years old
hey
does she like salmon dinners because my
boy over here pull a [ __ ] 20s piece
out of his ass
she's single birthday is it she's single
and looking
and the person who submitted her
danielle put in parentheses wink wink
theo
and uh she loves the outdoors and her
dog coral
who doesn't love the outdoors you have
to go you have to use the outdoors to
get to different places oh
god damn don't hurt him baby girl
where's she from
she's from sacramento california yeah oh
damn
shoddy got back she likes mixed dudes
who's that fellow she's with in the snow
is that nick van exel who is that
another guy from wisconsin you zoom in
on this guy who yeah
who's that mixed weary
that looks like my bear and i'm just
joking mike perry all love brother
all love yeah i love my i only say that
because you're a freaking human legend
baby
yeah with the beard with the beard it
does look like my fairy dog
it does look like mike perry did he have
his baby yet uh
i don't think so i think yeah i think
they did oh did they did i think so
bring up a pig man let's show a pic of
that beautiful he just apologized for
saying the n word i was just going to
say i wonder if that dog used the n-word
yeah this picture was taken during his
n-word days yeah
and look dude also don't shoot your shot
with theo and then take a picture with a
another man yeah that's uh yeah come on
girl but look it's mike perry you guys
i got some respect out there god dang
she is bodied
uh and look i don't think he had to
reply i mean where do you learn the n
word probably from music these days
here's the thing about the m word
most kids these days learn it from music
100 percent
so like very old is it that the n words
out there
yeah that's fair but also uh mike perry
did
uh that dna uh test and he
became oh yeah one percent black so he
thought he gave him free will to say it
look i'm not going to tell mike perry he
can't say anything oh there we go
cute daddy's drinking buddy okay
okay not the shirt on by my kid but okay
uh that's awesome man i bet you mike
perry gives his [ __ ] together after that
everybody's gonna lock it up man go on a
win streak that dad power
ain't nothing like it really oh
god this girl gets her ass on my face
i'm in a 12-step recovery program nick
actually i did have one more ah and he
sent a video so we'll play him
but i'll tell you first right now dude i
freaking got six cans of fix of flat in
my car
put in one more this morning and won
seven cans most i've ever had in that
car
ooh i might be uh let me know i gotta go
so i'm fixing it oh it's fixed
i mean it's but that's the problem i can
only go 54 miles an hour and the whole
thing starts rattling yeah
that's that jeep yeah it's great up to
53. i mean it rides great
just gonna boil what's up t1 brendan
this is alex from angleton texas
down south of houston i was just on
y'all's uh last patreon i'm the one that
got busted with weed
for you though man go check her out gang
gang buzz buzz
gang gang alex and he also said about uh
his aunt janet she's in her 50s but
still young looking
likes to drink and take pain pills to
keep her buzz
she's a type of gal she's always been a
gold digger and married two men for
money
hell yeah and her husband is now in his
70s and just
pissed her off when he retired and sold
their nice ass house for a trailer
living
she is not happy ooh so she's on the
prowl
that cougar prowl dawg that night
stalker
she also looks a little bit like a
weather lady nine news
i can see that dude 69 news huh yeah
that doppler dog yeah
come get this dobler
i'll say this i'll say this about janet
is her name uh yes
janet um
oh man hold on brandon don't say
anything
i'm trying to think uh oh here's a
suggestion a lot of women if you're
you don't know what's going on to get a
man you can do emt
work that way you meet a man they're not
doing well
you seem good bring them back to health
you get to see where they live you pick
them up from there
here's the problem though bubba all them
[ __ ] got coven
what all these emts that they're going
over these houses everybody got covered
that's why they're older
bro you call an emt cause you're dying
dude who gives a [ __ ] if you get covered
one of your
legs is broken you fell off the roof
doing freaking uh
bootleg roof work without uh without a
permit
yeah yeah you're right dude who gives a
[ __ ] you've been laying
she's she's not trying to get with a guy
on a ventilator you know what i'm saying
like that's a classy lady bro
i know but that's how you meet a guy to
know if they're a good guy
she's trying to meet a guy i don't know
drinks bang energy drinks you feel me
she does pain pills yeah but that's for
the pain of the people she picks up dude
it's transparent hi bro i don't think i
think she's that's
not her dateline that's what she's doing
and it sounds like a nice evening to be
honest she's that dalai lama dude she's
taking the pain for all of us man she's
that
she's basically the freaking she's that
third husband jesus christ
yeah you right we love you god we love
you god
uh let's move on some uh debate clubs we
love him though
what's up braden's up nemo got a king of
the stinger for y'all do you guys like
ninjas more
or do you guys like pirates more which
one do you think is cooler which one do
you think of winning a fight
also theo stop trying to get brandon to
go down to 240. if you want that smoke
you've got to go up to 250 and meet him
yeah you're right blame slang bus goats
culture vulture highlight oh dang
dude meet me at 260 right now bro meet
me at fat
yeah meet me at f-18
no matter where we meet at both of us
are going to be fat when we get there
and i have a feeling
unless we have two hundo yeah uh
pirates or ninjas pirates are tough i
feel like they lost their
uh luster a little bit with johnny depp
and all that makeup and [ __ ] and the dew
rags
you know that's just a hipster from
portland with a boat yeah
and then now pirates are really
ethiopians they kind of own the pirate
game
yeah it's my ship now them thiops baby
they call them
look great yeah somalia pirates
yeah oh dude the opinions run my bad
they make good coffee
they do yeah them thigh ops look man
this gray black feature shadow grab like
pizza also and thank you for
the support with that onward hoodie dog
are they still open great black
down uh i think they're still doing
deliveries
but i don't think they have any outdoor
seating but i'm not sure um
but also what was the guy saying ninjas
or pirates pirates are ninjas
which is cooler there's a thing that
happens when hollywood gets onto
something that they burn it out
yeah they burn it out dude and they
wrote them pirates into the [ __ ]
treasure chest
so they burn you know every now and then
it happens and they just burn it out
make a real pirate movie make it all
scary and you know real
johnny depp throwing jokes has eyeliner
on and [ __ ]
basically chris angel pirates of the
caribbean yeah it would be good if they
did like a horror pirate that's what i'm
saying
i like just blackbeard get real real
scary dude when i was on the semester at
sea we went on like a floating college
you know like school on
a cruise ship yeah i guess we'll call it
school they had
they had like a couple of oceans we were
traveling through where they would
say on the loudspeaker at night uh you
know these are the how we have to take
precautions there's pirates in these
areas
and by pirates they mean poor africans
yeah they're gonna jump aboard and beat
the [ __ ] out of you but how they would
do it they throw a ladder up then they
climb up at night sneak on oh i'd love
to see you
just get [ __ ] up by some slender
ethiopians
dude i look you're talking if it's like
an israel out of sanya yes i would have
a chance dude
if it's [ __ ] some dude named makimaki
okay i'm talking about the tom hanks
somalians just getting their hands on
you really
roughing you up dude for five rounds he
would need both
feet and two hands to [ __ ] even try
to choke me okay the homies
i'll slam that dude in a door yeah you
will okay
i'll [ __ ] tie a uh i'll tie some
straw to that guy's head and [ __ ]
sweep the floor
and you'll keep your money because of
being your butt yeah
oh they'll never find this
move so ninjas are pirates where you
land on your pirates are
too much jump the shark but also ninjas
ninjas
yeah what have ninjas have been cool
since the early 80s yeah turtle ninjas
ninja turtles are my [ __ ] [ __ ] can
you name all the turtles go
it's easy man go donatello raphael yep
michelangelo
and
leonardo that took you too long i almost
said da vinci
[Laughter]
now i got a question for y'all what's
harder to eat
while driving oh great question for taco
or some ramen oh wrong god that's what
unless you're in a tesla let me know in
the comments below
and if y'all want someone for a culture
corner you know
apparently a bunch of white people
watching this
throw my name in there
[Laughter]
i did 23andme it came back 0.1 percent
unassigned
you i don't know if you want to talk
about it
gang gang buzz
[Laughter]
that's great dude that guy is hilarious
evan or yvonne
that was that was my brendan
impersonation yeah and and also
ramen i got to know what kind of caught
whippies in too man
who gives a [ __ ] dude that guy's eating
[ __ ]
hot soup while he's driving and he's not
asian
this is illegal and he's not even
looking at the road yeah
she's talking a video he's talking to us
eating ramen what a power bro this is
the kind of guy that killed those 23
school kids in freaking kentucky dude
chin
will you [ __ ] tell us give this guy
the what for
this is your this is your feeling wait
is he even with a spoon or a fork
it looked like he was eating with his
hands for a second
oh that's a spoon just obvious
there is it a spork yeah that's if he
had a if he had chopsticks it'd be
easier
i mean i'm being serious too no yes yeah
if you're
able to get more control american
you have more control this isn't fear
factor though
what are you all doing the challenge on
mtv
enjoys goddamn lunch no if you know how
to use chopsticks
that'd be easier wait what's your
goddamn mind soup with chopsticks yeah
no on your lap on your lap chopsticks
it'll be easy
huh that's what you do i've done ramen
in my car before yeah you're korean on
the way to work
maybe you're korean you guys can do that
yeah level of difficulty with this man a
white dude
eating ramen on the highway stew's going
60
looking at us in his [ __ ] phone
what if they he died doing a king or
sting at submission
we'll throw that bull on the wall add it
to the hall of fame
all right we'll dip that [ __ ] in bronze
add it to the wall amen
along with uh taylor's nuts so we're all
firmly tacos on this one easier to eat i
mean it's definitely easier
i'm sure you get a [ __ ] gorgeous
crunch from [ __ ] taco bell i think
it's
easy to eat dude that's not a real taco
that is disgusting
taco bell is a place where high kids
hang out at okay
it's not a real food you learn how to
mexican pizza from there
i have but they were better when i was a
kid dude they got rid of it they got rid
of it
they got rid of it how could you get rid
of the mexican pizza dude
there's a staple in my diet as a child
it's crazy how
bad it got as i got older oh disgusting
do you think the quality of it got
because there is also a thing where they
decrease the quality of it over time
quality because when i was a kid they're
pretty [ __ ] tasty but do you think
that's because we didn't know any better
oh good point
my diet was mexican pizzas gushers and
[ __ ]
capri suns and that's why i'm thick
thanks dad what's this
oh i'm getting rid of the you don't like
gushers
you're a [ __ ] nazi no i mean i get it
but i just
just to streamline processes i guess it
takes a while what are they telling us
here what does that say nick uh they got
rid of it to streamline
processes for orders i guess that just
took too long for
yeah because it's the best thing yeah it
was too [ __ ]
hard shell tortillas fake meat in the
middle
beans on top cheese sauce
little pico de gallo on top and spanish
for salsa
i mean i i do remember whenever you
would order one
somebody who worked there okay
um who hadn't burned their hands on one
of the [ __ ] hot microwaves that day
would [ __ ] waddle over and
have to make something yes it would take
probably
40 seconds like those things aren't
ready to go yeah
they had to hand make them [ __ ] and
that's why they were the best
you get those and you get the [ __ ]
little uh cinnamon twist
those were good they stopped the
cinnamon twist too nuh uh
god damn if you play uh when i go in
there now i'll let the
i'll even if i i'll just ask for
directions and then leave
they do smell funky like how do i get
out of here
hey where's your exit especially now
that it's only uh
since you can't even hang out in there
like i remember when they built one in
our town first of all
somebody got arrested and they shut it
down because somebody did uh number two
in the meat there
oh that makes sense and they fought and
they had to shut the place down that
meat was suspect
i would go in those taco bells and use
the [ __ ]
yeah that's amazing man dude did you see
subway came out was like hey you know
our tuna is not real fish
no what yeah and everyone's all up in
arms about it you [ __ ] idiots thought
that was
real tuna you did
you dumb i thought some of it was no way
i thought it was maybe a 50
50 50 split
what i want to know is what is it though
what are they saying subway isn't
waiting for a judge to settle recent
accusations what does it say nick
uh recent accusations that's tuna salad
doesn't include real tuna among its
ingredients the fast food chain is
already appealing to the court of public
opinion with an advertising blitz
touting its tuna salad sandwiches and
wraps as made with
100 real wild caught tuna wild caught
come on doug
i can't go to my [ __ ] uh poppin sushi
spot nelly and get
wild caught salmon wild caught subway
that sounds very mafioso i feel like
you know so what's it saying it's real
or not i can't even understand that
subway says real subway says it's real
but someone filed like a court order
uh in the northern district of
california on behalf of california
residents
uh the suit claims the two were tricked
into buying food items that wholly
lacked the ingredients
they reasonably thought they were tricky
you're the dumbass that went to subway
in order to foot long
tuna yeah but you ain't getting ahi ahi
dog you're walking in
they have a green and yellow color
scheme okay jared from
subway started you [ __ ] idiots theo
slept with his sister
of course it's not real tuna i didn't
sleep with the sister there was
some oral laurel
dude i used to have this friend from
brazilian
uh i'm going to say this man uh what was
the key
subway tuna milk uh kicked her sting it
was
was that a king you're a student i don't
know what he said oh no he's saying
driving
or what's hard oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] ramen man
a double decker goes down smooth daddy
yeah
robin's heart's out smooth too you feel
me you're disgusting
grow up dude let's see what this guy got
but hold on one more thing i want to say
even jimmy john said this he said that
once your business gets so big you're
just fighting off lawsuits from people
about dumb [ __ ] yeah and that's what you
spend most your time doing and it's sad
like
somebody walked in there ordered some
tuna
got upset that it wasn't completely tuna
also get off jimmy john's nose
bro you got a promo code i'm teaching
you something
t-w-t-b-w bro 10 off jimmy john subs
god get off his nuts got a glowing email
from his team about the professionalism
of the tpw
staff and our whole operation really
yeah nice thank you very much also have
a also send
sandwiches though
[Laughter]
that dude brendan is the only person who
would be kidnapped somewhere he gets to
write one message in a bottle and it
just
sends sandwiches with no address
yeah furry also get off his nuts what's
this uh gentleman saying
a member of the village people
theo brendan eria nick
reporting live uh from tanamay desert in
the northern territory australia
yeah australia boys love your work
love the show keep it up look forward to
it every week
boys got a uh you can look at him
debatable
club for you this is razzle dangerously
hugh jackman or russell crowe
well this girl got sick bro
russell crowe same diet as us he's got
beautiful eyes russell crowe and he was
in cinderella man oh you're right
good [ __ ] pull there dude first of
all i didn't even realize till just now
that he wasn't cinderella man
second of all he came to the comedy
store a couple times and saw me do
comment i actually have his number in my
phone
oh text them see if i'll facetime in and
ask
gladiator too see what he says look at
that body and ask if he's doing
gladiator already bugged him about some
stuff he didn't respond so
i'm gonna back off but um
but dude he was the nicest guy he came
out to the comedy store a couple times
um dude hugh jackman's so talented the
wolverine
yeah can't name another movie though
uh what was the magic one prestige
oh hard pass it was great christmas
magician
hard pass
swordfish that boy's bodied up though he
got on that rock diet
it was funny he became wolverine and was
on the front cover of men's health and
like oh how'd you get so
jacked he's like well the rock called me
basically means the rocks on bunch
steroids
see hugh jackman did uh les miserables
yeah hard path
he also did that singing one
uh les miserables no oh uh the great the
greatest
showman oh yeah and it's zac efron's in
it
you don't realize that uh hugh jackman
can sing
you text in uh homeboy ask him for me if
he's doing uh part two gladiator
it's been a decade or more
i don't think they're going to get to it
brendan well
you have his number only one way to find
out
what other movie has he done i can't
find his number um
so i uh i might even have i might not
even have his number i might have
literally
been bothering someone who isn't russell
crowe he might have gave you a fake
number but
he's a great american gangster dude he's
done so many great projects
and now he produces a lot of his
different movies don't say projects
you're right don't say projects like
you're in the business yeah you're right
dude
he's done he's done a lot of great films
that i've watched
yeah beautiful mind great film oh god
when you think
bro he's underrated isn't he in a weird
way yeah he's a [ __ ]
like he's like he's definitely like but
he doesn't get thrown in that category a
lot of times
sin bro cinderella man alone was amazing
damn he's done a lot of films yeah
oh we did the one on the water too
remember where they're looking for
something
which one commander mailman master and
commander
mastering commander pirates i didn't see
it
but i will russell oh dude van helsing
dude the vampire killer bro it's really
a great this is a great comparison man
that's
really really tough bossys can hack bro
and gobble
but this australia versus scotland man
it's two freaking
underdog continents oh is he from
scotland yes brother
are you looking up nick i don't is he no
no you're thinking of uh
dude who did 300 nah he's from scotland
who's that gerard butler rod butler i
want president gerard butler
i was literally gonna say are you
talking about gerard butler
[Laughter]
sorry i've never met russell crowe
to gerard butler i'm thinking of russell
brand i have a buddy who's real friends
with gerard butler
and uh they're at dinner and you know he
loves women and he was saying
300 came out and this is like currently
you know he's out of shape you just get
older he gets
he's not you don't have that 300 body
anymore and he says he'll get in a room
with a lady
and they'll be like damn man what
happened like [ __ ] that was 10 years
ago
yeah i just don't stain 300 mode [ __ ]
he's like too late
gerard butler that's my friend right
there yeah that ain't your friend
the pride of scotland dude
he's a good actor bro he's a good actor
he was in
cinderella man
dude here's a crazy i bet he could just
tell people he was in cinderella man
that's a great part
um first of all this looks like razzle
dangerously the comedian
in disguise which i could tell second of
all i would love to have a wife from
australia so if there's any australian
women who will want to be a white
oh you want a down under 90 day fiance
dude yeah
hell yeah yeah britain you think i'm
marrying one of these american women
with all their freaking [ __ ]
okay i can see that you're on it today
doug and he even got stashed up at one
point
oh wow that actually that's a good pull
right there that is you're on it today
what else you got nick britney don't
move on because i'm having a nice time
are you tell us who else you know or
what huh you confuse whoever you know
sorry we took a break from the thousands
of people that you [ __ ] know for me
to name
two people and one of them i didn't even
know yeah
you thought you were a texan gerard
butler yeah dude my bad
and i might not even know gerard butler
to be honest with you
let me make sure i do that's what i was
trying to find out a minute ago
it was like when's the last time you
talked to him do i know
our father huh maybe just some of texas
hey man checking in
301 question mark oh
yes i do know him i'd love to see that
text comment no i can't share it because
he didn't text back
but it's not his fault he's a great guy
probably busy too
we know it's not his fault
we all know
this is andrew schultz
all right look guys i'm going to tell
you something straight up man what man
i bet on a couple fights ufc
recently yeah i've won some money from
you and i also won some money from
draftkings oh it's the only place to go
when you want to win bank bro
ufc 258's coming up you got freaking
basketball you got the lakers nugs
coming up and listen
listen up at draftkings sportsbook
they're giving you a chance to lower the
over
under that's right 1 000 players who bet
the overrun on sunday night's game
the over under will drop by one point
you'll see 258 coming up
do it with draftkings sportsbook they
offer great odds and promotions
basketball
hockey so much more all week long you
can also bet on long-term things you can
bet on somebody to win the pinning in
baseball you could
sure better win somebody to win the uh
hanley puck
or whatever you can win everybody can
win something you can bet on that who's
gonna do the election who's going to do
this they got long term options
next year super bowl last year super
bowl you know they got you can do it all
you can man make bank go to draftkings
sports
bug download the top rated draftkings
sportsbook app now use promo code kats
when you sign up you can figure out the
over under on sunday nights basketball
game nuggets lakers for every 1
000 people that bet they over in sunday
night's game the line will decrease by
one point all right
so all you gotta do is go to
draftking sportsbook promo code cats
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
minneapolis virginia only restricting
supply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler
or an indiana one eight hundred nine
with it one eight one eight hundred nine
with it
or in virginia call eight eight eight
five three two
thirty five hundo
let's see what this guy has to say yo
what up brandon what up theo this is aj
coming out illinois i got a debate club
for you guys today
if you're getting a new dog are you
gonna go with the classic pure breeds
you know your labs your
golden retrievers your german shepherds
are you gonna go with one of them mixed
breeds you know basically
anything mixed with a poodle those
hypoallergenic hitters
i personally got a mixed breed dog
mine's an australian shepherd
and a poodle mix and he's the [ __ ] but
i'm just curious about what you guys
think
are you gonna go with them purebred
fred's are you gonna go with the mixed
breed hitters
gang gang buzz buzz ooh
what's now daddy oh wow and they seem
like they know each other a little too
well at the end no
judgment no judgment the guy's also from
edmonton obviously based on the jersey
and you can tell that
it gets a little lonesome up there you
know that i got that hitter right here
today
man uh the new tie-dye which is on sale
right now and i'm also going to
say uh that's a good question purebred's
for the rich
purebred is for the rich i don't think
you have to adopt man i'm gonna stick
with andy santani on this one and say
get your dog that you want yeah also if
you adopt i don't need to hear about it
yeah every dog part oh he's an adoption
i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah he's also been sneaking out at
night and [ __ ] hitting the pipe
yeah i also don't trust them either yeah
it's kind of like you got that friend
who's a felon
yeah i know he's recovering done his
time but yeah but he ain't babysitting
nah can't be at the crib yeah yeah you
invite him to the party early so he
leaves early yeah yeah
hey yeah we're cutting the cake at two
once you get there about
noon yeah you're looking for a companion
not a burden
yeah yeah that's the thing man i don't
need a dog with emotional issues and
trauma
yeah i'll just call theo if i need that
you feel me i don't need a dog
praise god dude you want an emotional
support animal it's called this past
weekend
you can subscribe to it whenever you
want um
but i'm gonna say this chen why don't
you help us out here man i know you guys
have a lot of issues with petting your
industry
you you have a you your parents have a
dog right right you know it's just she's
like you're not doing well
wow yeah i bet he isn't living in fear
every time the
stove [ __ ] gets turned on [ __ ]
[ __ ] as soon as water is boiling
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah every time his lunch has a little
bit of carbon monoxide
he gets a little nervous he's probably
worried that he's gonna roll an ankle
and he can [ __ ] barbecue yeah
every time he's like oh this frisbee's
hella sharp that they're throwing
yeah i'm just joking too no
that's true though my people
unfortunately not
not on all of them no that doesn't do
what you got to do there's a lot of
stray dogs and
but there's an asian source the poor
people in korea
when i when i first visited we actually
me and my brother walked through the
marketplace
my parents didn't prepare us at all
i literally see i saw dogs cut in half
like stacked right and i was telling my
mom like what is this she's like
don't worry just keep going there's
https baby there's half dog stacks yup
poor people eat them yeah so did you
drinks on racks on
so did you try a full rack of dalmatians
i couldn't eat the whole day
the whole thing yeah you've never had a
dog tail the whole day
it was scarring you didn't try none too
no no i would never i love dogs did your
family no
they've never someone actually ate my
dad's dog when he was a kid yeah
he was scarred too yeah his neighbors
you know it's
but here's the thing we can't look down
on it man that's the thing it's
poor yeah what are you gonna do bro and
also half the food in america has
spiders in it dogs in it cats in it
the freaking tuna isn't even real it's
like the mexican pizza who knows what to
do what are we doing yeah so
yeah when people get judgmental about
how other cultures have to eat to
survive now i stopped at bad soup
bro get off the bottom of my dick
that's what i'm telling these people man
i think you eat what you have to eat man
you know if you want to [ __ ] be some
fancy girl who's like some
dog activist because you couldn't find a
husband then go over to korea and
protect all the dogs get a shield
okay and get a sword and protect all the
dogs batman are the [ __ ] dogs out
there
yeah tiffany all right whitney yeah yeah
yeah go do your thing just because i
want to eat a little horse i'm a bad
person
yeah just because i want to have a
little caballero
does that mean horse mexicans eat horses
thank you yeah mexicans eat a horse
that's what i'm saying everywhere you go
and we're the ones getting stuck with
the same shitty meat and then we get
articles it's not even really meat
give us the pup give us the horse man
can you imagine how
jacked our kids would be if we were
giving him horse at lunch at school
it's like alistair overeem that's what
he said he got so jacked he was eating
horses
but if you eat enough horse meat you'll
get the steroids it's in there yeah
true uh let's move on to some sync my
ink
brenda theater
got a little sink my ink for you what do
you think about that jailhouse hitter
boy
that 17 year old back of the party
don't remember a tattoo nah you remember
that
love you guys keep doing it and uh
gang bang buzz chug
boys made some bad choices well start
with that g unit tattoo
i don't know dog g unit was so good
remember how good they weren't good
enough to get a chest piece
get em up oh remember that no i don't
holla
going down i don't cause i'm around i
don't know that time jim remembers you
you remember it
yeah i hate her to love it that's a
classic gg
yeah go shawty it's your birthday dude
that album one of the greatest albums of
all time people
applause it was amazing it was lloyd
banks 50 cent
curtis 50 cent whatever his name is
gunshot wilson or something
and then who who's the other guy that
was crying on on uh
i recorded it buck young buck he was
just marbury too i think young buck was
crying
yeah was in the background eating
vaseline he got older 50 cents he's
gonna cut him from g-unit he started
crying
he started groveling it was it was so
bad it was terrible yeah but that's a
tough thing to hear
yeah he on the radio show he's like i'm
going to cut
no he he secretly recorded him on a
phone conversation and he
he's like groveling it was really sad
and he's still he's still going to watch
not killing it oh i'd love to see that
uh-uh i don't want it and was he going
like this i want to be in
the unit
[Music]
what if he made people stutter it out
when they said it
21 questions dude he had so many that
was the kids
this was that out this is just the album
right yeah this is a get richer by
trying but that's him that's just 50.
dude i'm patiently waiting for this dude
that album
gangster bro that album look at the hits
many men hi
like my style remember freya before he
got murdered or whatever
oh wankster remember wangster
wankster sticky you ain't got nothing
bro yeah they're still not good enough
to get a [ __ ] tattoo of them though
what i don't care how drunk you were
where's your g-unit tattoo bro
i didn't get one because i wasn't in
prison like this guy was dude no fusion
for selling perks bro now 50 is higher
in gianni
yeah we got freaking twink gianni's
working over there
he's on power right oh he's repping
everything he got a blm tattoo on his
back he was at the snl
after party with machine gun kelly this
saturday johnny was yeah
he's an essence fan he's performing at
essence
[Laughter]
he's on the cover of ebony magazine yeah
dude he's a backup dancer in the whitney
houston hologram performance
he's not killing it bro but i'll tell
you this man he
the show that they're on is pretty wild
man people dig it right yeah
i watch it my brother loves it though it
gets tons of advertisement it's like a
soap opera kind of it's kind of like
um it's like a black people soap opera
yeah it's like nine o'clock it's like
90210 kind of like it's like melrose
place
like yeah yeah um
i'm gonna be honest i haven't watched it
never i haven't watched it either
tim dillon said it's for dumb people
i look i'll go out and live and be like
this storyline is
pretty slim you know there's like
flashes of guns there's like a lot of
looks across the way like uncertainty
a lot of like secret meetups like
espionage yeah
i'm not into it it's soap opera dude
it's black soap opera it's gonna be on
for a long time though it's doing really
well it looks like a bunch of spin-offs
johnny get his own spin-off he's yeah
he's a lead on the spin-off it's in the
second season
and he's one of the favorite characters
he's like the token white guy just like
he's like himself he's like white mike
yeah yeah yeah but
uh this guy i got another sing my name
and he's dating a black girl now
yeah standard yo what up king in the
sting this is
alex from phoenix arizona we got to sync
my ink for you
now it's uh not my ink but it is kyle's
so shout out to kyle
in the facebook group for posting this
the self portrait tattoo
me personally i think it's a little
homoerotic to have another man's
face on your body but it is what it is
and it's not my body
thanks guys for all you do i think it's
the best podcast in the world just keeps
getting better shout out brendan theo
chappelle cat nick and chin
gang gang buzz buzz gang bro and your
neighbor is a leaf blowing a little too
early in the morning for me
or this guy you know he's working from
home it's two in the afternoon
some no matter what his neighbor takes
away obviously the neighbor takes care
of their driveway yeah you're right
and i respect that but hey now this
isn't homo erotic because this dude got
a tattoo of himself yeah
and stevo was the first one to do that
yeah and stevo had the largest one until
he met another guy who out largest went
in
so now he's the second largest i thought
that was jeff foxworthy
uh i'm serious
that's jeff foxworthy if he failed
foxworthy
that's a failed jeff foxworthy i don't
know
that's not jeff foxworthy this guy
looked like he came in last place in the
jeff foxworthy contest
i don't think so man dude that is is
that jeff foxworthy
that's what i thought the whole redneck
thing was for jeff [ __ ] worthy dude
this dude likes to [ __ ] bro dude
dude definitely zanbar and chill over
there bro
you know you're a redneck if you have a
picture of yourself tattooed on you
yeah definitely blue comedy torn chill
huh
he's watching ron white on repeat yeah
bluechew.com
hell yeah littlebluechew.com little blue
collar
comedy tour oh yeah have the blues
[ __ ] i'm tired i don't wanna [ __ ]
uh we'll close out with a couple king at
her sting
what's up guys this is eddie from
chicago i have king her singing for you
i saw an article earlier about um us
putting chips in monkey's brains
for neuralink i sent the article to nick
my question is getting a chip in your
brain
king it or sting it well i know a guy
could use one i think i think uh you and
i could both use a little chip in the
brain
i'll take that i'll tell you anytime a
dorito homeboy i was gonna say who can't
handle a chip in the brain it's freaking
chappelle's dark ass dog that dude
couldn't handle a chip in the brain he'd
only put a little bit of it in
yeah he'd be like chip i'm hungry who's
talking chips man i'm hungry man
yeah he's always hungry huh yeah yeah
feed him man he works
he works with he has money you get your
own food dog you know get a pringle shut
the [ __ ] up
yeah dude some shark they caught some
shark doing only fins
you know unless this brain technology
company neurolink has implanted device a
monkey's brain
to make it play games in its own mind
this is legal but we can't eat dalmatian
yeah this is legal but i can't have that
[ __ ] faux tuna at subway
i can't order a [ __ ] dalmatian
it's bone-in filet at the [ __ ]
uh at the steak house at salt grass dog
i can get a monkey to play video games
with me but i can't get a mexican pizza
yeah there's a [ __ ] legal chimp now
who has ideas in his head
there's a legal champ who's getting
ideas sent from a computer
but i can't get a facial reconstructive
surgery
on a [ __ ] owl that i found in my
neighborhood dog elon musk can get us to
mars but i can't get a direct flight to
nashville and jetblue
come on bro facts were you telling me i
have to lay over in [ __ ] salt lake
city today for no [ __ ] reason yeah
it's frustrating
[Music]
i'm pissed sorry you guys have
headphones on
i'm sorry it's okay i didn't mean that
and here's some girl or this could be my
sister too
kangaderstingt would you date someone in
a wheelchair
yes i would hell yeah she uses a walker
she's going wherever i want
one go wherever i want
[Laughter]
would you date someone in a wheelchair
or
that uses a walker
and brandon don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
do they
[Laughter]
oh i'm an [ __ ] one one joke about
[ __ ] wheelchairs i'm an [ __ ]
brandon you [ __ ] ripped everybody
that said anything yet
but these are good people brendan yeah
everyone we're all good people this is
the show
man you know we're not they're trying to
get life advice
man dude i'm not [ __ ]
i'm just saying i i think it would be
dope to date a girl in a wheelchair man
man you could go wherever with her but
you can't not if they have brakes on it
man
and also just pick them up uh uh uh you
could i couldn't do that
yeah i remember my girlfriend sprained
her ankle one time in south carolina and
i couldn't even carry her to the car and
i felt so sad man yeah
god i remember that i just set her down
like seven times
take a break yeah i had to have a water
break oh yeah i felt
so bad do you keep asking if she has
liquid iv
i had to keep leaning her against the
wall and [ __ ] literally it was two
blocks
and she like rolled her ankle pretty
good we were playing hoops she was good
at hoops was she a big [ __ ] though
that's different man you didn't want
them heifers
she rolls her ankle you guys playing
one-on-one basketball
no she gotta carry a big ass to the car
but yeah i kept having to set her down
i set her down in a car too and it was
hot she got all pissed yeah
i think it's done unbelievably sad
i feel sorry i'm sorry about that yeah
i'd like to know some background why
she's in the wheelchair though
we don't know if she was she just had a
wheelchair there she was on the ground
the chair was to the
side i think they should have wheelchair
ufc and i've been saying this
that's not a bad idea and they just ran
into each other
murderball was tight on an mtv but there
was no murder in it that was the thing i
thought in the end somebody died it's
just people [ __ ] throwing a ball
around yeah
that's kind of like the tuna subway
stuff if you're gonna say
tuna i need tuna if you're gonna say
murderball i need some murdering
yeah dude don't [ __ ] tell me murder
and give me mackerel
oh and there's chin in the background
number six sneaking over
and look i wonder if that guy if it's
easier to be like that
and eat ramen or eat tacos that's what i
want to know
what's easy random wheelchair tacos are
robin that's a great question what's
easier to wheelchair and eat
taco if look if you a young lady and
what is her name rebecca
johanna did she say it larissa
i don't think she said her name alpha
ivana
there's a wheelchair wheelchair boxing
on youtube
street beefs youtube it gets a little
the weirdest thing on youtube is those
backyard fights that's what those are
it's always uh yeah shogun versus
fat allen you know it's like crazy yeah
there was one real guy and then one yeah
dude it says hell on wheels versus mr
mud
is mr mud's not a wheelchair no they're
both [ __ ] out of the guy in the
wheelchair they're both on
it's always like the same name as horses
they're like oh it's dennis's ambiance
versus uh tuesday come early
who the [ __ ] are these fighters dude
and it's one blind guy versus one
[ __ ] black dude on steroids
he should go to one oh do a lot
do a king of the sting live from one of
those yeah
and you and me are the commentators damn
we just light them up before they get in
the ring
and then get out no no they're going to
beat the [ __ ]
off that's how we get beaten dude
and you're going to have to defend us
you're not going to i'll have to fight
dada five times
yeah he just said he just had kidney
failure when he fought kimbo
yeah he died his heart stopped in the
middle he stopped in the middle of the
fight he died
kimbo head butted me dude in my hometown
in [ __ ] 19
in 2002. and i'll stand by that title
the only concussion he got
uh the guy in or the young lady in the
wheelchair her name was frankie
actually shout out to frankie man keep
doing your thing girl keep rolling on
uh we'll do one sting king so dude if
they had a fighting group called sting
kings you know those guys fighting
king of the sting fight club
we get some cash you quit being a little
[ __ ] with that grand
they get cash and hot sauce pour his hot
sauce
pour his putting the belt on him you
know the commentators
yeah we could even get chin the ref we
couldn't even get nick and what's this i
know we're supposed to
go in the parking lot right now
dick take it to the stream wait y'all
spidey's supposed to be today i know
it's literally it's supposed to be
today or yesterday or something february
2nd when was it supposed to be
i didn't know we made a date i missed
that but the end of january are you
feeling frog your nickname now you're
right there
i'm saying if you guys bring in boxing
gloves i'm down that's my time
opportunity we got some boxing gloves
and theo's like
it's called two pair dude no look those
are
gloves that i use privately to train and
i'm auctioning those off for the good
fight foundation
nah [ __ ] that they'll be worth more
money if these two got a little blood on
them
yeah they are dry who's right-handed uh
both of us oh that's no right hands
that's our fighting league no right
hands no right hand
it's like when jason ellis fought uh
shane carmen got knocked out
one-handed idea they tied one arm behind
shane's back really and jason had both
and shane knocked him out no way knocked
him out cold
bad idea wow i told him before i was
like dude don't do this
he did it that's braving him though man
we got army hammer calling in
jason else is brave as hell yeah he is
and the crazy part is i grew up with you
named jason ellis that was always on
pills and [ __ ]
similar yeah but could he skateboard
no that's what people know but the best
thing was they were at a party one time
just hanging out and out of the blue he
was so high
he leaned across the table and he told
like this hot girl that he wanted to go
down on her in front of everybody and
what she said she's like
[ __ ] yeah it was
so strange bro chain's so big
is he oh my god he fought ufc
heavyweight world champion bro he
knocked out frank mayer with an
uppercut against the cage and then he
beat the [ __ ] on brock lesnar but gassed
out oh my gosh wow
and that's it huh dude me the war shane
and i used to have were not his wife
telling him get up
you get up get up baby
hey guys that was a good one that was a
bad idea it's like conor after the
dustin fight
is this conor in a couple years
hopefully not
i'm joking that's ice cold connor's a
legend he went back in against him
crazy yeah what a psycho no i think did
i think they stopped right no they
didn't they're not stopped brendan this
is going
shane got some cheeks on him too
that was a cheap shot right there though
shane of plays dirty man you know he's
uh he's oh my he's a water
engineer shane's a smart dude what does
that mean he's a steroids
in texas oh he knocked him out again
yeah yeah old right
no i think that time he just knew he'd
had enough too uh that one's that's true
so bro jason always fought this guy
dude that guy it's like seeing a bear in
the woods it's a bad idea
yeah put your food in a box and stay in
your tent
or climb up a tree a bear can go up a
tree
yeah you're right you've seen bears
scratch their back on trees yeah it's
cool huh
yeah we'll close it out with this kicker
does that look like army hammer no this
is me dude after my first comedy special
[Laughter]
brendan theo adam here from toronto got
a king at her stinger for you
with the winter season upon us
turtleneck who is this ralph waldo
with the winter season upon us also you
live in canada bro
that's your season yeah okay there's
only one season man
sorry man i interrupted you though
please go on brother with the winter
season upon us
turtlenecks keep you warm also kind of
make you look like an uncircumcised
penis
they make you look speaking of which
there's that big dick in the sky right
now we got the cn tower oh that's mine
got the sky though right there
theo had a great time at your show back
in february and uh brandon was supposed
to do a meet and greet me and my brother
actually back in march at your show here
but
uh unfortunately the world went crazy
and that got cancelled so bring him back
down i'd love to have you all back at
some point
but uh anyways love y'all let me know
what you think gang gang buzz buzz
buzz buzz young turtleneck man
turtlenecks are pretty spicy dog
it looks you look fancy in it oh you
seem rich you seem like a ski person
yeah i went to some rich guy's house in
nashville and everybody's wearing
turtlenecks and
it was good you are a turtleneck i wore
one for a birthday to that no well you
wore a white turtleneck to that [ __ ]
kid rock's 50th oh was it kiddo activity
i thought you guys were in the capitol
that wasn't me so you saw a rich guy
wear it so then you're like oh this is
what i'm going to wear at a kid rocks
party
no well i knew i knew that that that i
that i needed to get something nice
mine was more of a one of those like
ambiance necks
no mine is the thicker fuller
fat aunt turtleneck dude i see a guy in
tronic i think that guy
[ __ ] you do oh yeah oh thank you pride
drives the mercedes [ __ ]
oh yeah probably has coke in his back
pocket
you wish yeah
yeah that's it dude where does
turtleneck on the plane today on that
layover dog
sauce on sauce on them daddy i love salt
lake city but some of the
airports some of it's uphill in some of
the parts you know
and it's a stretch when you gotta go
from concourse a to c
you look in a three mile up hill hike
son
dude one thing i always wanted to do is
either in the madrid airport or the
atlanta airport go for a jog when i have
a long layover
you do that in chicago like literally
there see they have that ambiance neck
dude that's neck neck no it looks like
you wore that a few times and got
stretched out
it could have man i haven't i've been
doing a lot of neck work yeah
praise god dude god damn don't get a
white power handstand well who is this
guy
dude that guy's he's either super
successful he's just lost that guy is
awesome whoever he is dude and yeah he's
in the bathroom of an overpriced airbnb
as well i'll tell you that
on the episode where we were talking
about this theo snuck in another one
at one point i i there's a freeze frame
he goes three other people had it
[Laughter]
i love how they're like all these
treasoners on the capitol it's like 19
[ __ ] dudes from arts and crafts
in there and just one dumbass got shot
the one lady
it was a man no it's a lady she got shot
oh she's like let's get him she was the
first one got shot in the neck
that would sting dude i don't know if
you even know
it was kind of a game over you know i
think you know
oh i don't think it hurts so i think it
hurts like a split second
she was like let's make america great
again we got shot right in the neck
by the security guard off
well can't wait man lesson learned learn
from it theo if you're gonna do it again
learn
learn from it dude i was there i look i
was on the hydration team my job was to
keep everybody hydrated
liquid iv liquid iv guys promo code
uh i'm in tampa end of the month i think
26 27 tampa florida
come get some tampa
bag shop like a wrestle even though we
never rock mask
and you know cat's gonna take your
breath lucky she got nine lives cause
she fresh to death
and i hope i don't come off strong i'll
make you log off when i'm in the dms and
i'll send another hot dog
just kidding didn't send that pic that
would be too premature
just like nick i'm slick i'm sick too
legit to quit
they be calling me chappelle cause i got
the trick and tell me how am i supposed
to live without chin singing he gonna
take
[Music]
i think you'd be
[Music]
one surprised years ago they tried to
okay
years ago they tried to tell me you
don't got the stripes webby now they
call me conor mcgregor cause i got a
tiger belly i'm prophetic my kaveli
thuggin like two pack homie dalia cause
my pocket's heavy cheeto cause my rock
is ready when it's time to rock
call the bird or get his chopper ready
now though browse palm sweaty probably
vomit mom's spaghetti in a state of mind
always try to keep a balance so i'm
younger than dalia but my soul is always
calling your brandon looking like he
live with 16 kittens
and theo looking like he yells for when
fishing
tight no foes don't matter god bless me
like i
got bad allergies this boy might just
burn white rabbits like thick boy bike
club burn those calories
[Music]
take first place
here we go
okay
you